any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
it is such a treat to you know it's
always a treat to do these interviews
with with the greatest luminaries and in
science and leadership and technology
and culture but it's all the more fun
when you get somebody who is a friend a
mentor a collaborator just an all-around
great guy I think you're known as you
know the world's most likable physicist
so David Kiser welcome to the into the
impossible podcast right thanks so much
I'm glad to see that my checked you
ahead of time is clear that's a good
test that I bribed you say those
wonderfully nice things but I'm really
just delighted to join you and I really
appreciate the chance to talk with you I
love all your books you are actually I
should remind our listeners you were the
first guest on the into the impossible
podcast when he came to visit UC San
Diego about three years ago four years
ago maybe now in 2016 that's right it
was only audio none of those fancy video
stuff on the other hand we were able to
sit next to each other and not have to
be a continent or six feet apart that's
right yeah it's in our cases the
continent and six feet apart I mean we
we we go the distance literally so we
are here primarily to talk about two
things I would say what you've just
released this month the book entitled
quantum legacies now available as
published by the University of Chicago
Press and but the other thing is we've
been kind of taking a little mission the
new mission statement for the podcast
and that's really deconstructing the
kind of greatness of high achievers in
all different fields we've had on
artists and we've had on astronauts and
we've had on plenty of physicists and I
and I really you know just just
delighted that we can talk with you and
hopefully glean some insight into the
various different hats you wear from you
know your wizard cap to your professor
had to your author hat you've written
several books now and I can never
pronounce that the honorific chair that
you have occurred
since Nelson you obviously could not
it's the big game is thousand I have
other dear friends who like to call it
the Gewurztraminer chair which puts you
in the right spirit nice sweet dessert
wine no it's the the grimace housing
professor of the history science also a
professor of physics here at MIT yes and
the new book quantum legacies is a
wonderful book and first when I you know
I kind of began reading it with the
thought and slight trepidation to be
honest that this would be another
quantum mechanics book there's been
about 27 of them published in the last
year about from our friends these are
people we know and we love and they're
good books and they're you know and it's
it's always funny when each one sort of
purports to be the definitive you know
this is the only description of quantum
mechanics that you'll need and before I
picked up the book and started reading
it during this disco vid period of
quarantine and I like to tuck into about
eight different books at a time I
started to think god I hope it's not
another quantum interpretation book and
I said I wonder what that stands for an
a quid not another quantum information
book and of course you know this being
an expert in Arabic etymologies that
word when they're not clip in Arabic
means he who investigates and verifies
so I'd like to add that to your
honorific I think you got a clip chair I
will talk with the folks who control
such things I now have a new mission
I'll send the emails as soon as we're
done talking here that's great so the
[ __ ] is a wide-ranging I have an
electronic form only I would you know we
were not allowed to get deliveries for
any other through the normal channels of
the hardcopy but I'm going to get a hard
copy this is a follow up in some ways
I'd to say physical copies exist it has
real pages yes fashion book is it's out
in the world but it's hard it's slowly
getting out the world because yes I see
and what I what I immediately tried to
do is sort of compare it and contrast it
with your previous book and well roll in
some footage of that how the hippies
save physics published in 2012 and that
was that was a real tour de force and I
think that actually
this new movement I have to say into
this re you know vilified interest in
the foundations of quantum mechanics do
you want to just comment did you was
that your intent when you wrote that
wonderful book oh thank you right so so
I I think the order of operations a bit
reverse you know causality is a tricky
concept but in this case I really should
correct the the record near that book
which is just enormous joy to write how
the hippies save physics I really just
loved the the ride I've been here work
on that but I don't think it's it's fair
to say that that that book helped
jumpstart a return of interest into the
quantum additions my interest in taking
on that topic was certainly inspired by
many many colleagues all over the world
who for many years but up until that
time had already been really doing
deeply creative deeply challenging and
exciting work
in a kind of revived field of quantum
foundation so the order was certainly
other super-smart dedicated people
digging into this with all they had I
was getting more and more excited and
interested in it and and had this
opportunity to write the historical look
recent history you know 40-ish fifty
years old not not going back to the
Renaissance or something like that but
historical really not this super
contemporary time period on the other
hand again as you well know one of the
really fun and and for me really
unexpected outcomes of that was that
after my book had come out with some
friends and colleagues of mine dear dear
mutual friends of yours and mine
together like Andy Frieden read the book
kind of for fun and then that helped to
spark new discussions among our own
little group and so it brought me into
more active work as a physicist in the
field of quantum foundations the field
was doing very very well without me
until that time to be sure and continues
to but but working on the historical
study helped really remind me of some
things I had I had been glancingly kind
of exposed to were aware of ahead before
working on the book more squarely it
opened up new things I hadn't known
anything about beforehand and then at
even after the book itself it really was
was a pretty strong catalyst for what
grew into a really thriving a
I think very exciting fun international
collaboration that that I've been just
delighted to be able to take part of it
yeah and that does of course a major
element of this book that we'll talk
about it's near and dear literally to my
heart here in San Diego we have a mutual
colleague who is described and even
pictured in the book dr. Andrew Friedman
that we'll get to when we cover this
book what's it what's nice about this
book is that it's kind of a
choose-your-own-adventure
in that you can really get the sense of
the quantum mechanical impact on various
and disparate fields ranging from
cosmology to the early foundations of
quantum mechanics the history of quantum
mechanics and all the way up there in a
popular culture and weaving its way
through how physics pedagogy and even
scientific STEM pedagogy is taught to
this very day the impact of it is really
traced so beautifully in this book and
you know being a chooser on an adventure
book really offers the audience a lot of
ability to kind of pick and choose these
delightful tidbits its exhaustively
researched and referenced I checked
every reference you know several times
typed in manually every single URL and
everyone was correct so that's wonderful
I do that with all the books especially
my children's picture books you know the
board books you have to check the
references and those board books you'd
better be careful that's right I want to
begin with the conclusion because it
kind of reminded me is almost like a
mission statement of the book perhaps a
vision of how you did it it's the final
chapter is about Stephen Hawking or
uncovers your your distant entanglement
with him and you never met him you say
in the book I met him once
when he was giving a lecture at the
Royal Society and it was very
interesting speaking of books and I hope
to spend some time today talking with
you about your feelings about books and
have they impact your life and why you
became a writer but Stephen Hong was
talking about his book and during the
question and answer period he was still
able to answer questions not in real
time but you know five-minute 10-minute
delay and this is in the mid-1990s when
someone asked him you know professor
Hawking at the end of the talk why did
you write this book it's rumored that no
one understands it in its completeness
it's so complex
it's so Byzantine and difficult for the
layperson to understand and yet so many
people have it what was your purpose in
writing it and he responded in a slow
you know computer synthesized voice I
wrote it because my daughter had to go
to college and of course it brought down
the house but his humor was so
mischievous and you talked about how his
personality really had you know spoken
to you just just as much through the
final configuration for lack of a better
word that his that his that his
countenance his face was left in was one
of this mercurial smile and how it
impacted I knew I want to read from the
the last sentence the last part no
spoiler alerts we're not gonna I don't
typically like to ask you know can you
explain your entire book so that nobody
has to read it no I want people to buy
every single copy and hopefully the one
outcome will be you do an audio version
someday but anyway
the last sentence is I never met Stephen
Hawking but the idea of him and several
of his ideas have been with me for much
in my life
may his example continue to inspire
young people to beat the odds and to ask
big ungainly questions about the
universe it seems like he did have this
huge impact on you and of course we're
observing the second anniversary just
recently of his passing Einstein's
birthday who also appears in this book
tell us a little bit about what Stephen
Hawking meant to you
to quantum mechanics and the legacy that
he cast over the union of quantum
mechanics in cosmology
that's a great question Brian thanks so
I didn't ever meet him in a sense of
having anything like a direct
interaction I was in rooms with him so
in that sense I was near him physically
on a few a very small number of
occasions and that was as you know and
perhaps many folks you hearing or
listening to the podcast would also know
from footage or from their own personal
experience you know it was a really
striking kind of experience I first got
physically physically proximate to him
and I say that didn't meet him but was
close to him
when he came to visit for about three
weeks in the autumn of 1999 so just over
20 years ago I guess he came to visit
Harvard to give a series of public
lectures some of them very broad
public lectures for non specialist of
the sort that he had gotten very very
good at and a few more technical
lectures a intended for specialist but
given his star power at that point they
were still held in in an enormous
auditorium because every wanted to hear
even the esoteric stuff and he therefore
he and his you know team of nurses and
assistants and grad students and really
the whole kind of entourage there for a
set up shop for about three weeks in the
physics building and I was just
finishing my my graduate work there so I
had a little kind of desk in a shared
office in a different wing of the
building and so I I was there a few of
times into the sort of early to middle
evening again certainly I never I never
had the gumption to interrupt the
professor directly I didn't feel that
there was a need for that he was he had
enough on going on but I think it tends
to talk with some of his students and
the nurses and just the kind of support
team around him and and being near in
the room and that itself was really
fascinating you have the constant any
kind of compressors and various kind of
medical equipment that's keeping him
really really going and then I don't
want to call in an or I don't wanna make
it mystical but it was just a sense of
this was not a man not an ordinary
encounter but there was a kind of
constant hum and a buzz of activity some
of it literally a boss from the
instrumentation and otherwise just a
kind of you know a sense of this is an
unusual unusual thinker in in very
unusual situations and I found that
really that really stuck with me of
course it'd be much younger than that I
was in high school I he's you and I were
both in high school they were basically
exactly the same age yeah the perfect
age to be that's right we were you know
when he when his a big most most famous
book came out I was a mid to late high
school student I fell in junior years I
like that a brief history of time and
and you know I certainly grabbed up my
copy like so many people around the
world had done and I really did read it
or at least tried to read it through by
that point I was already a concerted
kind of popular physics junkie I was
devouring lots of books we lost
something very very good popular books
they were just coming out over the
course the 80s on physics and cosmology
on quantum mechanics and some wonderful
juicy topics
and this was another one and for me this
was another one in that series but that
already been kind of hooked and I did
think that there was a kind of
especially charming way that Hawking had
put that book together which you may
remember he has you know some compelling
analogies and metaphors about abstract
phenomena about a black hole even a kind
of what we would call a classical black
hole without even worrying about the
complications from quantum theory he has
passages in there about the Big Bang
that has come to occupy so much of my
thinking and yours in later years but it
was interweaved with these kind of
personal reflections or little stories
about about his personal life which was
such an unusual kind of journey and
looking back that was actually pretty
unusual that became a more common um
almost a kind of template let's say for
writing books you and I each you used
those devices in some of our own more
recent books I don't think it's a bad
one but I think Hawking was ahead of the
curve and trying to really write not
exactly a memoir or an autobiography and
not exactly a kind of depersonalized
popular book that only talks about
concepts and analogies it was a
sometimes a very sweet and charming and
even moving kind of combination so I was
hooked on on let's say an image of
Hawking in that sense from when I was
pretty young and then roughly ten years
later I was at least sort of getting
into the field myself and had this kind
of close encounter let's say and then
even a little more recently closer to
before he passed away I was involved
with a number of colleagues agree to be
on the order of 30 colleagues writing
really basically just a short almost
like an op-ed length kind of popular
article about some of our current
understanding about the early universe
that time could have roughly near the
Big Bang and we had invited Stephen
Hawking to be one of the kind of
co-signers co-authors of this short
really just a few paragraphs and so we
with so my smite my own senior
colleagues and co-authors sent the draft
they had they knew Hawking reasonably
well professionally and we got back an
email the next day where he basically
objected to the phrasing of the Oh in
paragraph two and my colleagues who'd
known him
some of them for decades it up that's it
he won't do it he's he's he's so
stubborn
you know you'll never change his mind
and I being innocent of that experience
sort of naively said well it's not a
crazy suggestion he made his suggested
edit what if we just knew tweak sentence
number two and add a semicolon and what
if we just tried to edit it and respond
to his actual neil earnest feedback okay
so we do that we send it back and then
the next day we got another email saying
he agreed he liked the edits and he'll
sign on and the kind of your moment of
euphoria do you realize that I still had
never you know interact in any serious
or substantial way with Professor
Hawking but but I had I had into some
small way beaten the odds by by getting
around his his legendary stubbornness so
so I had these moments of attenuated
encounters but as you as you rightly
said I mean many of the ideas for which
he's so well known in our field you know
they have been with me in one form
another and I think with you and so many
of her colleagues since we were very
young people now we get to work we have
the great privilege to work on many of
those ideas and try to nudge them
forward in our own work today and and
that's just incredible and and I guess I
did like the fact that you know later in
life you'd appear in comedic YouTube
videos with Paul Rudd playing quantum
chess he'd show up in the sitcom The Big
Bang Theory he clearly had a kind of
sense of self that he knew he was this
kind of icon and very unusual scientific
persona but he seems at least in these
outward appearances to at least on
occasion not take himself too seriously
let let let himself play with the notion
of being this crazy hyper famous very
unusual kind of person and I thought
that was just so delightful and as you
say his you know as a physical disease
war on to my mind I thought his his face
kind of settled into it what I did call
that impish grin and that really kind of
made sense to me yeah that is certainly
in a notion that it seemed you know very
authentic with him it wasn't cultivated
or forced and in some sense he who was
he seemed to relish this this role of
being in society and and obviously the
the film made about his life
was that was another kind of indelible
mark that he left on the culture as well
as on the physics itself I think there's
many and you're much more scholar about
the history of physics in particular but
you know there are these notions of
physicists especially Einstein and
Hawking that are almost supernatural and
you wonder you know it is it really
deserved at a certain level and you know
thinking about Einstein he actually
certainly does seem to earn that title
based on everything that he did
accomplished in his life and how
inventive and creative he was and I
think you know what was interesting
about about Hawking was that he he was
okay with changing his mind and he was
he had that same scientific sort of
dispassion where he wasn't you know
entirely consumed with the notion of his
legacy and that somehow burnished his
legacy even more famously not changing
his mind as our mutual friend Sir Roger
Penrose would say you know it doesn't
matter if you agree or you know if you
believe this about black hole
information paradox are the opposite of
that because you're in agreement with
Stephen Hawking either way you know
thinking about him and then one of our
colleagues here the director of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination dr. eric berry PhD MD he was
one of the flight surgeons that went to
certify that Professor Hawking could fly
in zero gravity along with right doctor
Peter Diamandis MIT alum and the two of
them you know kind of teaming up for
this wonderful you know brilliant mind
to slip the surly bonds of gravity and
play in these in these gravitational
playgrounds it was just it's a delight
that we have this connection and I think
you know the the linkage between between
Hawking and and the thread that runs
through these books I'm sure that you
get a lot of requests to review books or
to review book proposals you know one of
the things I never knew about the about
the you know the process of writing the
book and again I want to you know thank
people thank you publicly in front of
everybody for endorsing my book blurbing
my book added to
to the pantheon of physics royalty who
endorsed it but I never knew that you
know books went through this proposal
process and the construction of books
and I want to talk about books in
particular because you are so voluminous
Lee creative in terms of public you know
popular science as we'd say trade
science but you're also you know a
day-to-day card-carrying physicist and
capable of doing and having contributed
to many significant breakthroughs and
and path forward not just in quantum
physics but also in cosmology including
a very I predict in particularly enjoyed
this description where you spoke about
this this theory of tangentially related
to the Higgs theory and spontaneous
symmetry breaking and really being
candid that you had some ideas and
essentially you got scooped and I want
to take our listeners through what is
the similarity what is the contrast
between writing say for the popular
audience and writing a technical paper I
mean it's hard to imagine you get
scooped out of writing how the hippies
you know save physics but or this book
but how is it working on the front lines
of scientific inquiry being pursued by
perhaps an unknowable mass of of people
arrayed you know to to compete with you
well ya know it's it's it's a good
question so these days my main way of
coping with that is trying best I kind
of surround myself with extraordinarily
talented very hard-working young people
how do any of us get anything done at
all you know wizened age and we but and
I I joke but it is the case that having
a bunch of pairs of eyes among close
colleagues and collaborators including
students and advisees you know so we can
we can we can each be taking a turn kind
of looking not exactly over our
shoulders I don't mean to make it sound
like we're all kind of paranoid
sometimes we are but but let's say
there's you know the even the little sub
sub sub fields even the specialties
within specialties in which we aim to
make our contribution you know those
those have have in general grown in size
over the lat even just in the 25 ish
years that I've been active trying to
contribute to these things
that you know you really look over the
our beloved preprint server the archive
you know pretty much every day because
there's because the odds are better than
even that someone did something
interesting or novel or curious or
something that you really better be
aware of you know many days of though of
any given week of every week of the year
weekends you know and evenings included
it's relentless and it's exhausting and
and I find I can only try to approximate
kind of keeping up in that sense I
really it becomes a team effort even for
theorists I mean unlike you I don't for
my theoretical work in in early universe
cosmology I'm not building instruments I
don't have you know an enormous team to
try to get to work together it might be
you know two to five people but we just
need a couple pairs of eyes both to
think through our own ideas and refine
them and work hard and it's the kind of
pleasure they're actually a genuine
pleasure of just getting lost you know
losing the sense of time and which I
still get that feeling getting in the
kind of zone when you're winning is
really deep in the calculations you just
want to know but there's all and and
that's fantastic and there's also the
role of what are our other you know very
smart colleagues of whom there are
seemingly more every day or at least
lots and lots of them what are they what
did they do last night
what what do they post to the archive
you know in the last day or two or three
so that's a long way of saying it it
does take even for for theoretical
investigations I think it takes you know
more than more than one person trying to
juggle push the ideas forward check and
recheck and make sure we're not fooling
ourselves or making some mistakes and at
the same time keep at least some level
of awareness what's out there now coming
to to your larger question the timescale
of that it really is kind of day-to-day
and the time scale for me at least of
trying to think about a book you know
they're quite different so the the
hippies book I wrote from in what was
for me lightning speed and I say that as
a joke they fit faster than I wrote my
earlier book right by a lot but that's
still men it's measured in years not
days or weeks and so it's a different
kind of different kind of intellectual
work to
try to keep scales of a kind of an
argument of sources of every footnote
that I know Brian's gonna double-check
you know by hand where the thing comes
out there's just a lot of moving parts
in a monograph that's gonna be on the
order any 300 pages in a thousand
footnotes that's a different kind of
objects than a physics article that
might wind up being seven pages with you
know thirty references and so so I so
it's a different series of kind of
mental steps for me at least I tend to
think about what's the overall big
argument what's the kind of arc for a
book that I and it kind of emerges from
the mists you don't know it all at once
right away and then how can I kind of
operationalize that what are the parts
of that but I need to get straight to
contribute to this overarching argument
that I ultimately think is original and
interesting and hopefully some people
might find you know I learned from a
financial so that means think about
chapter structure about different kinds
of sources historians always talk about
primary sources and secondary sources
what have other scholars other
historians or scientists or sociologists
or philosophers what a favorite bout on
related topics and then what is what's
the gist the kind of newer cool stuff
that hasn't basically been out there
that other people haven't been scouring
or aware of things that weren't
originally published private notes or
correspondence or unpublished grant
proposals or whatever the kind of
materials might be a lot of interviews a
lot of my historical work even in this
most recent book has been fairly recent
history where many of the people I'm
writing about are still alive so I can
talk with them or email or some
combination a telephone or whatever and
so there's a lot of ways of gathering
our art what we might call data
historians will call it kind of evidence
of primary sources and what how do those
fit in different kind of bins in the
chapter structure in the overall
argument and that that whole process is
very iterative a lot of going back and
revising and thinking through again and
the natural times care for that is
measured in months and years not not
days and weeks
that's a really intriguing way to look
at the the differences between the two
but also yeah there's similarities I
mean I found it fascinating to see you
might construct an equation and a series
of sentences a paragraph that takes a
month six months you know and then data
obviously can take years to acquire to
massage and then to to get into a
publishable form what I can't and I
don't know if it was by design but it
was sort of the different themes in the
book echo through the different ways in
which the universe reveals itself to us
and I always say as astronomers we kind
of have a more challenging life than
physicists experimental physicists do an
experimental physicists can take two
protons and smash them together
traveling very close to the speed of
light and see what kind of a shrapnel
and debris emerge and then they could do
that you know protons are fungible after
all so they can you know do that many
many times they can do different things
and actually do true experiments and see
how the results compare to the objects
that are under control and Quarantine
like we are all now but but in but in
effect astronomers have a much more
challenging
you know task in front of them and that
we can't really do an experiment where
we ask we change the temperature of the
Sun you know how how affect the density
of neutrinos going through the earth at
a given moment right and in your book
you cover really the three different if
you like a phylum of ways that
astronomers and physicists can probe the
quantum through matter in the case of a
massive matter perhaps in the form of
neutrinos you talked about the origin of
the of the theory that neutrinos have
mass rather Pontecorvo and others
neutrino oscillations right the
experiments that you're involved with
and then an experiment very close to
your home at least originated very close
to you at MIT the the famous LIGO
experiment which uses waves of
gravitation and not waves of light or
neutrinos in any way and then regime of
of kind of massless messengers that come
to us from deep space you spend
time in in a fascinating chapter called
quantum theory by starlight yes
which details the origin and evolution
in your role and and our colleagues our
mutual colleagues Jason Colicchio and
Andy Friedman along with Anton Zeilinger
group in Vienna and you described this
detective story and I wonder if we can
go deep on this particular chapter again
there's three different modalities that
physicists can taste the universe and
that's really all we get we get that and
a couple of meteorites and that's all I
get from mother nature or God it depends
on your perspective so it's walk us
through the quantum theory by Starla
what intrigued you and I mean look
you're very productive physicist you're
a very productive author you're a
teacher you're a well respected mentor
now you're dean for some reason you got
hit on the head with an i-beam now he
came so mean so you're not the crusty
old Dean or just the associate the old
Dean a young Dean tell me how do you
decide to turn your attention to a
subject like this what what what
criteria does it have to pass in order
for it to you know be worthy of the
Kaiser the Kaiser rule yeah I wish I had
a rule over with the the chapter you're
afraid to Brian that quantum theory I
started as as you know it's it's about
these experiments that we call the
cosmic veil experiments and I mean
really without without question just
hands down that whole experience for me
has been just an absolute highlight of
my career of my life it's been just this
unbelievably rewarding you know kind of
roller coaster emotional roller coaster
an intellectual one but just a rewarding
adventure and I just I can't say enough
how lucky I feel to have been able to to
work on it to experience it to try to
contribute reward it met a number of new
colleagues who I now because it are
really very very dear friends as well as
others who were already friends I got to
work with it was just just a series of
wins all around plus it was just really
cool we learn some cool stuff and you
know the added benefits electorally as
well so and again that's the project
that grew in some you know non-direct
kind of nonlinear way had at least part
of its our origins from my or
historical book that look on how the
hippies say physics what's really a a
kind of history of who cared about
topics like quantum entanglement went
before that topic had really become
mainstream in the physics land before
kind of all of us knew we better pay
attention to teach it to our students
and put in textbooks there's a long
period during which some of the ideas
were being clarified but in small little
you know enclaves and not really
percolating to the whole discipline and
that's what I was immersing myself in in
that historical project and then with
Andy Friedman and and then with his good
friend from grad school Jason Colicchio
the three of us began talking soon after
that book had come out about what what
could we bring to the topic of quantum
entanglement and especially these
experiments these kind of relentless
efforts to test quantum entanglement
which themselves had stretched over 40
years by that point now nearly this than
50 years that what can we bring to that
on unfolding discussion from our vantage
point as astrophysicists or cosmologists
who had not been very central to this to
this topic for much of the history and
so we began thinking about what could we
what can we use from our day job it was
one of our day jobs which is to study
the the kind of contours of our cosmos
of our observable universe over
timescales stretching back to the time
of the Big Bang itself roughly fourteen
billion years ago and as you know very
well and you've done so much to help us
all learn we've understood what we can
call the causal structure of the
universe so over that fourteen billion
year period when the universe is
stretching it stretching we know at
different rates at different moments in
that history some sort of region some
locations in space could have been able
to kind of talk with each other by
exchanging a light signal and others
could not have yet and so there's a
causal structure could an event a
possibly haven't had an impact on event
B where and wet and and one of our jobs
as cosmologists is to kind of map that
out and see how that causal structure
has changed and evolved over over the
fourteen billion years of our observable
universe and so we learned to bring Andy
and Jason I wanted to bring those kinds
of questions and insights
to bear on a topic that is usually
considered actually only on kind of a
desktop scale and a kind of human or
smaller scale meaning quantum
entanglement the behavior of pairs or
triples or multiple particles that are
prepared in special ways it won't happen
you won't see this effect if you take
any two random particles but especially
prepared say pairs of particles and we
can perform experiments on each member
of those pairs and we find these
remarkably sort of surprising
correlations in the outcomes it's almost
like if people would remember the
newlywed game you and I remember that
game no it's real you can go but barely
any any kind of quiz or you imagine
asking questions of two people who are
kind of isolated from each other so they
shouldn't be able to cheat and confer
they shouldn't be able to kind of make
their answers agree by talking or
exchanging Neo tweets or whatever so you
have them in like isolation boots and
you ask them a series of basically
questions at random and see how often
their answers agree when you try to
shield against these kind of cheating
mechanisms where which would which would
make it clear why their attribute agree
okay so we wanted to bring the kind of
causal structure of the Kosmos how could
a of influence be to bear on these
questions on why do pairs of particles
in these experiments show such
remarkable agreement when asked
seemingly random questions and they're
kind of far away from each other and so
our our answer our proposal really which
we dreamed up just the three of us at
first was to try to use random numbers
from the sky we wanted to turn the
universe as big enormous gorgeous
universe that we are lucky to be in he
turned that into basically a pair of
random number generators as if the
universe were flipping a coin on our
behalf of flipping two coins separately
and so what that meant in real terms was
to perform real-time observations of
pairs of very distant objects in sky on
opposite sides of the sky so the lights
come in from one side here and from the
other side here - if super careful the
light could only have gotten to this
receiving station before it could have
gotten elsewhere so again there's no
opera
for the kind of cheating or coordination
that we're trying to shield against and
now you can play a game and say well
depending on your budget and/or the
patience of your collaborators you know
how distance a pair of objects do you
want to aim for to bring to give you
this kind of random signal on very very
short time skills in our case frak
really just tiny fractions a second an
effective microseconds million for the
second so it constant taking in new
observations of these of different
astronomical objects in every fraction
of a second and turning it into
basically a plus 1 or a minus 1 we what
we actually were doing is measuring the
color of the light of that object is it
more red or more blue in that window
compared to an average color for that
object and separately for the other
object there we first did that with
bright stars in our own galaxy Milky Way
stars that are far from Earth in human
terms they're trillions of miles away
they're far in galactic terms these are
like our nearest neighbors are among
argue this name that's nothing right
these objects emitted their light
hundreds or thousands of years ago in a
fourteen billion year old universe
that's that's an eye blink in cosmic
terms so we did our first test using
these small hobby telescopes the they
were Mead telescopes you can literally
just commercially buy them from kind of
astronomical hobby shops great they
worked great they had I think eight-inch
and 10-inch
you know kind of collecting zones not so
big and then on the strength of that
pilot test were we by which I really
mean my colleague Anton Zeilinger
who is both an extraordinary physicist
and a very very effective negotiator and
had to say to her luckily for us he
basically was able to talk our way into
some really gorgeous absolutely amazing
professional telescopes each of which
had a polished mirror on the order of 13
feet across and like form four meter
telescopes on a mountaintop in the
Canary Islands the island of La Palma so
then with these much bigger light
gathering surfaces these huge telescopes
we can do that same thing is the light
this microsecond more red and more blue
but not from you know nearby stars but
from very distant quasars extremely
bright
galaxies the light from which we receive
just that moment on the mountaintop have
been traveling for much of the history
of the universe for eight billion years
on one side for 12 billion years on the
other side so now you're talking
genuinely cosmological distances all
that is just to take in random numbers
from the sky in a way that we assume
were not connected with each other
partly because that causal structure
argument I mentioned that were not
received on earth until the very
fraction a second that we happen to open
up the telescope and look and click so
it couldn't be kind of previewed by the
other parts of the apparatus on the
island all that's just basically as if
we were flipping a coin to make random
choices every split-second but what
measurements to perform on this pair of
entangled particles that we made that we
created here on earth that Anton and his
amazing group created using a pump laser
and a special set of electronics and
it's really amazing a special crystal
can split the beam in very specific ways
it's awesome I mean watching them at
work was for me just just I mean jaw
drop they're absolutely there really was
and so the entanglement that we were
able to measure the the really quite
extraordinary evidence we were able to
add on top of generations of positive
evidence that had been there for now
nearly 50 years was that we find these
spooky correlations in the outcomes of
measurements on these earthbound
particles they're far from each other
they're on our experiment or dirt a
kilometer or two apart so they're far
away they can't be cheating by talking
in real time they can't send the light
signal at that moment to say I just
answered plus one make sure you do as
well but they're answering questions
that were determined by these really
cosmically distant random events and so
we put all that together as we called it
a cosmic Bell tests the Bell part is
named in honor of the physicist John
Bell we added the cosmic part and it was
a way to try to ask you know could the
world be as strange and as as
counterintuitive as our beloved
equations of quantum theory tell us
relentlessly tell us this is an
avoidable feature of quantum mechanics
as smart people have clarified over over
much of a century
is is the world working that way or just
our equations and we wanted to test that
that basic tension as thoroughly as kind
of as creatively as we could turning the
universe itself into a kind of Claire in
that in that adventure I was a long
answer it shows you how much fun I had
putting it together they grew into a
team of uh about 20 people so you really
took a lots of people to get you know
the electronics and the astronomy and
and the theoretical work and it was just
an absolute delight it was fun from day
one due to yet yeah that is uh it comes
through with great clarity it's an
adventure story as a scribbling notes in
the book you know kind of has this ain't
your this in Indiana Jones and and your
colleagues obviously Andy Jason and Tom
etcetera and the young graduate students
and that really made me think about you
know how do we train these people if you
say to somebody you're gonna learn about
quantum mechanics and you're gonna do so
you know in a with a twenty-foot
shipping container you know as it flies
down the side of a mountain in the
Canary Islands if you if you look you
know if you're to you know tell somebody
ahead of time that that's what they were
going to encounter maybe they wouldn't
want to sign up they'd be a little more
hesitant to turn down that job at
Goldman Sachs or something but I want to
do now segue into this topic of pedagogy
you're known as a as a master teacher
and you have a cadre of compatriots that
you have learned the craft from but I
wanted to kind of take a step back into
you know the origin of pedagogy as you
talked about in the sort of the atomic
section of the book where you you look
at the atomic legacies a nuclear age
with legacies and the fact that World
War two was declared to be the physicist
war so much so that physicists would get
police escorts and have top-secret
clearances and and even go to these in
one of the thirty nuclear sites around
the world of course few people a lot of
people know about the Manhattan Project
it's been detailed it's made its way
into the psyche the neuroses if you will
or the zeitgeist you know for many many
decades now fewer people know about the
radar project that was led at Lincoln
labs and in my team that eventually led
to explosions in the knowledge of of
the atom but of the cosmos because it
led directly to the development of radar
technology that became radio telescope
technology that led to the discovery of
the Cosmic Microwave Background which is
what I studied yes and so there's a
direct line through that war what again
I don't like to you know really reveal
too much about the book so I'll just say
that the the description of how you know
physicists attain this prestige and even
the prestige dynamics within the field
of physics in other words which subfield
of physics is it more prestigious to be
a member of theory versus experiment
nuclear versus you know electromagnetic
magnetism condensed matter now we have
biophysics and I actually do want to
segue into that again I don't want to
talk too much about the you know give
away a spill the beans of the book I
think it's such a wonderful journey I
don't want to spoil it but I want to act
get your impressions about two things
one is what will the outcome of our
current war which is this war against
this invisible enemy called the Ovid 19
virus and how we can our the corona
virus and the Cova disease associated
with it and how it may have the ability
in some way despite the tragic awful
loss even of a single life of course
being so exponentially tragic but could
there be any positive outcomes for
example could you envision that as world
war ii was the physicist war that
perhaps this war may it always be
peaceful among nations but but against
this enemy could it lead to the
biologists war and perhaps as the by as
the physicist war led to the you know
what was called the century of physics
maybe this will be the century of
biology it's a very interesting question
probably I have a lot of thoughts on it
so this pocket goes seven hours is that
right yeah that's right yeah that's that
midway point for most of them yeah good
I have my lemonade I'm good I'm good for
the hall yeah no I you know a couple
thoughts number one even just very
locally here at MIT partly because I do
have this new administrative role this
Associate Dean thing
with my very dear colleague mica
Associate Dean Julie Shah we've been
working very hard locally and with
colleagues even at other campuses to try
to actually connect researchers in many
many fields not just biological ones who
didn't often have the opportunity to
kind of meet or work together because we
do think this challenge requires you
know a really many headed many many
kinds of expertise it will be required
and so in locally that means economists
including really quite renowned
economists who are experts in health
care and public policy experts in
management in logistics and supply
chains think about making sure hospitals
have an even even a little bit of the
equipment that we know they're gonna
need let alone as much as they possibly
can how do we smartly help
decision-makers allocate things computer
scientists and modelers even even
theoretical physicists let alone people
who really know about these things
there are standard modeling techniques
and epidemiological modeling but some
really very powerful newer techniques
and how we estimate parameters these
things how we do real-time data analysis
and we've been able to help not only us
of course but in within in dialog as
many kinds of colleagues put together
teams it's not actually just sort of
biologists we obviously need
epidemiologists and biostatisticians and
public health officials into and and bio
physicists and and more but what's been
what I didn't quite foresee ahead of
time was how much groups could be
coagulated you know that in maybe some
unexpected ways with with even more sort
of eyes on including historians and
anthropologists medicine what about you
know compliance issues in previous
pandemics it's one thing to have what
looks like a best laid plan but if it's
having if folks you know don't believe
that's gonna help them or or don't trust
the authorities we tell them to do it
then you have another set of human based
concerns to worry about so it really
does require a huge range of expertise
I'm gonna now I'm gonna tell you my
thoughts on the war analogy I I actually
I'm worried about the repeated use of
the war in
to describe the current pandemic
challenge it's an emergency it is an
enormous challenge around the world as
we know with clarity every day here's
why I bristle at the war analogy when
people make the reference to the
Manhattan Project to a radar a great
example that you mentioned I think in
the in the current context I think what
they mean is we and with this right I
agree we need enormous resources we do
need in fact multidisciplinary teams as
those teams indeed have been in the in
the 1940s we need resources priorities
and many eyes and hands on the job it is
a super high priority and it is a matter
of alas a matter of life and death
ok that's that's that's a pretty good
analogy to the Manhattan crashing the
rad lab the kind of emergency footing on
the other hand you know every war at
least everywhere that I know of in human
history ended because humans made
decisions to stop fighting we can't
negotiate with this pathogen right it's
not a war in that sense what and if we
if we continue sitting up in a war frame
with them within when does this war end
what would victory even mean we're not
gonna eradicate this thing it's gonna be
around on the earth you know probably
forever at least it's more likely to
soon that that other ones and the
meantime let's take those examples that
you mentioned the Manhattan Project the
rad lab they they functioned because of
two kinds of secrecy and I think we have
to be super careful about both of them
right now and really avoid both both
projects at the time were classified
from the general public no one could
know about them who wasn't very very in
a very small circle of experts so
there's secret from the community and
there was enormous compartmentalization
even within them
general lovely Leslie groves who really
managed the entire Manhattan Project was
very very concerned about things like
espionage and so he wanted to make it
nearly impossible for any one person to
accumulate too much information on the
whole project so even experts who had
clearance to work on it could not know
about what kind of neighboring efforts
were doing and and and we don't we can't
have that today either so we can't be
doing this work in pride in secrecy from
from the from the pub
that we want so much to to try to be
helpful with and for and we can't do it
in mutual ignorance either and so how
that one of ways that manifest now is
you know people who work on for example
on epidemic ma modeling of the parameter
estimation we have to make our code
publicly available right it's not enough
to write a paper with your equations of
your model we need to see how the codes
implemented and they say that because
with some colleagues just the last few
weeks I've been involved in some of this
epidemic modeling myself some
quantitative modeling modeling skills
that I could try to lend and we found
that we couldn't reproduce at all the
results of one group that had written a
paper in public but we don't know they
didn't release their code we get nothing
like what they did several of us
independently implement trying to input
their model we matched each other
nothing like within their paper so we
can't figure out what we're doing wrong
or would they work another group we
found a bug in their code and it
actually led to a pretty important
different way to interpret the output of
their of their models but we could find
that because it because that other group
really had done when I consider the
right thing and it made their code fully
and easily and freely publicly available
those are pretty important dis analogies
from the wartime efforts high-priority
multidisciplinary life-and-death yes
it's not a war because we can't
negotiate a surrender and we can't we
just can't do it with the kinds of
secrecy internal and beyond that had
marked those projects
yeah that's a those are those are all of
course very important distinctions
between this and of course you know war
is usually a zero-sum game and I guess
the thought that I'm thinking is you
know perhaps there could be it could be
a positive sum game not for the virus
but for resiliency of future responses
we know that these viruses don't go away
they're almost impossible to cure
quote-unquote to vaccinate her
permanently obtained herd immunity is
very challenging and so especially these
novel viruses and that mutate that
evolve and so we all hope of course that
these efforts including yours will be
successful as a associate dean as an
associate dean I want to now turn to the
role that universities are playing have
played in perhaps will play in education
and I take note of the fact that there's
an awful lot that MIT in particular does
to open-source their your your
productions your lectures not every
course but there's a tremendous amount
of OpenCourseWare I believe is what you
call it and it's and you've been doing
this for a decade I mean you could find
videos going back decades
yeah early 2000s yeah that's right and
they're just phenomenal I use them
sometimes in on preparing courses here
in San Diego but kind of putting on two
different hats one is as a cynic and one
is as a futurist so as you see things
going in the future
if this continues and if we don't get
swallowed up by Kurtz Wiles singularity
different singularity than those that
you and Stephen Hawking another so study
but if you go forward still come a time
when you know instead of my students
reading Brian Keating's interpretations
of David Kaiser's lecture notes on
quantum mechanics you they can sit with
the real one not you but your avatar
your hologram something like this and
they're not too distant with Einstein
himself I mean would you rather learn
you know and sit down and ask notes to
and and say don't don't laugh at this
joke like ehrenfest does in your book
but but would you rather do that with
you know someone some-some
you know it's novice like me compared to
compared to an Einstein so looking
forward putting on your future
artificial intelligence goggles where do
you see the future of this
OpenCourseWare going and then and then
that's the optimistic question and then
I have a cynical question for you to
address as well oh if your Dean had on
so first do you see this being a
possibility accelerated bike Ovid to
really upper gains as educators and
perhaps move to augmented reality I
don't know what they are meant to be
elegant I'm sure there will be at least
at the margins I think you're right this
will this will boost efforts that were
already ongoing because now if if for
much longer we're all staring at screens
people get creative at how we at what
screens we stare at and what we do with
them so I think you're right there there
that's likely to be one outcome I do
agree I think MIT not only and I do but
I think MIT has been really very
proactive now as I say for almost 20
years in in trying to make pedagogical
materials available for free online with
very few barriers or difficulties to
accessing
open courseware is a great example it
was the first one that we launched in
something like two thousand three or
four and really goes back quite a way by
now now that has some classes that are
in some sense capturing your full video
lectures full assignments even
assignment solutions and all that a lot
of it has pedagogy materials that will
be helpers for self-study but not really
a substitute for the full class some
lecture notes not the full thing maybe
not video taped lectures but some you
know hopefully helpful materials but not
not quite a substitute there are other
platforms MIT and other schools have
have even more let's say could have
immersive pedagogy mitrios online as
well and on this score I'm done I'm very
proud that we have been so proactive in
getting these up there we read these
testimonials they still come in every
day I mean from literally all over the
world from people who are really making
use of these materials and who are at
least Express real real gratitude for
them
and we think about you know that kind of
reach I mean being able to hopefully at
least ignite the imagination let alone
hopefully teach something even more
specific and concrete to people who
might never get to wonderful places like
MIT or UCSD or or any of our wonderful
homes that I think that's you know that
honestly gives me chills I mean we let
how can we do that more and better and
more and more effectively so that's all
good I still and enough of a if not a
Luddite at least a kind of old-fashioned
person say on the other hand I still
think there's something really really
very important and and so far hard to
replace from in face small group you
know in the room together kind of kind
of interactions pedagogical or otherwise
and so I don't think you know when we
can all safely come come back out of a
self isolation of course not all of us
in self-isolation many people are very
bravely you know out there in essential
jobs even now but when the rest of us
will who I know it's non-essential types
I mean you and me a particular bride
well we can get are allowed safely back
out you know I I think we will have
learned to do more things online
effectively because of this forced
period when we're doing them only online
I don't think it's going to be a switch
that's thrown and I think there's we're
gonna rediscover things that we both
enjoy and maybe just still do better
face to face you know pointing to this
thing on a blackboard or really having a
genuine kind of constructive interactive
kind of debate or discussion you know
kind of closer than only six feet away I
don't think that's going away and I
think we can get better around the
margins and we'll do more and more
things in the ways that we are kind of
forced to try to adapt now I don't see
it as an all-or-nothing
so as the optimist I think we're getting
better at some important tools and
hopefully one one effect of that will is
that we'll be able to bring some high
quality materials to even more people in
the world and I think that we just a
great great outcome of this i but I
don't think we'll stop you know doing a
very ancient thing which is scratching
one kind of rock on another
chalk on a chalkboard I mean think about
an unchanged pedagogical technique goes
back kind of to the Greeks they're
certainly doing long way back yeah but
you know having a kind of [ __ ] everyone
shared not just seeing the same thing
which we can send out kind of do but
really being kind of co-located I don't
think that's going away yeah I'm sort of
you know teasing about being a true
cynic I do think that there will have to
be a role for these for these you know
compete competition for attention for
focus and they think there are values
too you know
just as a simple example you know we
both have boy-girl twins and minor
mirror twins are yours also are no no
okay so we our symmetry is broken
literally there but but I right we have
married we have twins and boy girls and
one of my daughter's she was you know
she was looking at me and I was talking
to her and I was being you know my
normal animated self and she tried to
like swipe my face you know she tried so
I was an iPad for a second and you know
Amy think about you know when I
introduced I got these Google what are
they call so the Facebook oculus yeah
years ago and my you know five year old
at the time he was really into it and he
just like on the space station like
floating through it and it's so visceral
that it's impossible to think that there
isn't a role for that in the future I
don't think that could be the only role
as they said you know sitting down with
me versus Galileo and learning about the
principles of Galilean relativity I know
who I choose and you know I don't have
as big an ego as as as Galileo did but I
would still choose him and you know at
the same time I do think that with the I
heard an interview I think it was with
the president of MIT it might have been
somebody else but a very prestigious
university there in Cambridge perhaps
the one that begins with H and he's
saying when you meet there was and he
was asked you know like how big could
your university be I think it was at
might and he said we could basically
double triple you know the the the
quality of applicants yeah you could
double or triple so then with that being
said and with the fact that you have all
this open courseware and with that with
the notion of accepting
you know some role for for electronic
pedagogy and perhaps augmented or
virtual you know virtual reality you
know is it is it fair to deny you know
some bright student in Mumbai you know
the chance just because she's not able
you know she didn't win the Hunger Games
application you know competition to get
into MIT which is just so selective or
Harvard or wherever UCSD even we turn
away a tremendous number of people and
I'm just wondering you know in this era
where you know I'm teaching my kids at
home you're probably teaching your kids
as well I forget how well they're but
but you're probably at home and you're
putting on your hat and I'm just trying
not the toilet trained my my graduate
students while I'm teaching quantum
mechanics to my two year olds but right
right we probably benefit by the way
from that yes I think I think they
they'd all have their own unique
experiences I I'm a little more cynical
that it universities will have to adapt
I mean I say this even with my kids and
their school you know and they're in
public schools here and elsewhere you
know just like anger and frustration
like hey my kid is you know I have to do
it but you know that it's two hours long
and I'm covering everything that you
said to cover you know
so we'll pedagogy grow in that realm I
agree I think people will all have to
have you know the kind of sage and the
stage but as you pointed out you know
that model at least goes back to the
University of Bologna in Italy and fry
for but but at least in the formal
university setting to that phase in
history and the you know Middle Ages is
basically 1100 or so and my favorite
anecdote from back in the anecdote but
just tidbit trivia it's hit I'm not
quite that old but is that the students
used to go on strike if they didn't like
you know professor cars or professor
Keating they would go on strike and you
might think oh that's great now a fewer
students to teach no no you wouldn't get
paid that's right on the other hand as
you know they can get their degree until
they threw a feast in your honor
so that's right you came around the
other way too I try to remind that I try
to remind my advisees of that but you
know commencements been announced but
who says you can graduate until you
throw them a big fancy feast for your
professors but without that I didn't end
it we weren't originally playing to talk
about set
which is chapter 14 in your book oh I
would love it if you would indulge me
and talking about it just very briefly
as we begin to wind up this this
wonderful conversation I'm having a
wonderful young author named Sarah
skulls on my podcast tomorrow she wrote
a book called they are already here
about aliens being among us for
potentially in the popularity of aliens
and culture she previously wrote a book
called making contact about Jill tarter
and the Allen telescope array and and
our friend Seth Shostak and your chapter
14 you know kind of harken back to a
conversation we had here at the Clark
center the one of the last conversations
before we were shut down of public
lectures and that was with Paul Davies
of who makes an appearance in your book
of Arizona State and the and the origin
scent or the Beyond Center rather at
Arizona State University and of course
he wrote a book called the eerie silence
and in fact we celebrated back in
January the 10th anniversary of its
publication and it was written on the
50th anniversary of the beginning
project Cosmo which he talked about and
then and the SETI program and the Drake
Equation being constructed I wonder you
know and so therefore the SETI kind of
the notion of SETI search for
extraterrestrial intelligence is 60
years old this year
and you have this wonderful description
of it and he talked about Frank Drake in
his famous equation and I wonder and at
one point you actually draw linkage a
bright line connecting the nuclear age
myth the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence can you take us into the
Drake Equation and drill down into that
one crucial critical term that we have
almost no idea about and and how it
links the atomic age with the you know
the nuclear age with this with this
quest for alternative extraterrestrial
technology and intelligence sure no I
divide it again remember I'm certainly
no expert in SETI though I did enjoy
learning about it and written about it
here but as you say Frank Drake
introduced who's been a very
famous equation in the early 60s I think
was 1961 it was really a way originally
to help organize discussions he wanted
to organize different teams at a kind of
upcoming conference or workshop who
would each take on parts of this big
kind of many headed challenge and so he
was writing down terms that would
ultimately be like what would be the
likelihood to to expect to receive a
signal from some intelligent
extraterrestrial civilization and so for
that you'd have to have you know a rate
of galaxy's form a rate of planets
habitable planets that form around
certain kinds of stars and all the kind
of Astrophysical things that people
assumed at least would be prerequisites
for life Atlee he says we would
recognize but know it and the very last
term in his equation was basically the
average lifetime of such a civilization
and in 1961 in the heart that sort of
immediacy of the Cold War that wasn't
always taken to mean how long told some
smart civilization blows itself to bits
with nuclear weapons as indeed was a
very real concern for many many people
around the world in the 1950s and into
the early 1960s and Beyond and so he'll
the last term in this famous equation
seems other way so you know a undie
personal right galaxy formation star
formation plant information all these
wonderful rich topics in in astrophysics
in biophysics and so on and the last
piece which it seems to kind of hinge
upon is for us to expect to receive a
signal they would need to have survived
long enough survived themselves long
enough to build the technology to be
ready to send out signal so came back to
a projection on are they gonna blow
themselves up and are we going to as I
argue it's and certainly not only me who
said it a lot of this feels like a kind
of projection from ourselves onto the
sky I don't mean say it's merely a
projection but it certainly our
assumptions about them are revealing
about what we think about us and and
that really has stuck with me since I
first learned about the Drake Equation
again so if it's a high-school student
it's not only Frank Drake some of the
people who were instrumental in that
even two years earlier like Philip
Morrison
we're also a gun kind of deeply embedded
in a nuclear world let's say even more
directly than Frank Drake in Morrison's
case Morrison had worked a Manhattan
Project he actually was on this
so-called advance team who was among the
first non-japanese people to inspect
these sites that have been bombed in
August of 1945 by the atomic weapons the
Hiroshima Nagasaki Morrison became very
politically active after that especially
in the matters of arms control and and
Dino nuclearization and 50 almost 15
years after that very dramatic
experience he begins working quite
seriously on astrophysics and what will
grow into SETI and again he's sort of
looking for beacons of a kind of benign
gentle other a kind of wiser version of
ourselves out there partly I think
because at least I suspect because he'd
seen some pretty awful things that we
could do to each other right here so we
have this sort of moment of creation of
SETI in his modern form in the late
fifties and early sixties that's
inescapably bound up with with nuclear
matters then there may be less expected
interactions in in more recent times so
SETI has had a checkered history in
terms of is it improved by either
scientific bodies or by in this case the
United States federal funding agencies
yes-no yes-no has a kind of bumps along
on the other hand there have been some
pretty dramatic technological spin-offs
much like say with the apollo program
other big massive science and technology
projects SETI
pioneers should rightly take pride in
being very very advanced in certain
kinds of signal many many multi-channel
signal processing and other fancy
electronics and data stuff some of which
then got reincorporated back into
nuclear testing so you have a kind of
return the other way about some very
cool advanced techniques thing develops
to try to look for you know signals of
other intelligent civilizations that are
being kind of refolded back into some
nuclear testing and simulations here and
my favorite example actually comes I
learned it from my very dear friend and
mentor Peter Galison is a very
distinguished historian and physicist at
Harvard and Peter
has been working on this effort to to
try to how do we deal with our own
nuclear waste on earth many people worry
about that of course but when you have
kind of half-lives of the materials that
are so far beyond the kind of human
experience tens of thousands of years
maybe even hundreds of thousands years
some these very exotic isotopes then are
produced in the in the course of
producing weapons or materials for
nuclear power reactors how do you
dispose of those and then warn future
generations who might not speak English
why should we think English will be
around 300,000 years from now might not
read newspapers and you get the idea how
do you communicate with our own future
selves about again what can become life
and death machine knows don't dig here
that stuff can still make you sick even
though you have no notion of what the
year you know 2000 or 2020 could
possibly even mean 300 thousand years in
the future 150 thousand years so this
group to try to figure out how to
future-proof that one kind of outcome of
the nuclear age brought in experts
including experts in SETI how do you
talk with some kind of radically distant
other in a way that you both hope will
recognize as a form of communication so
you have this kind of many step many
stages dance between SETI and and
various aspects of our nuclear realities
over the course of 50 or 60 years
so I think will I want to conclude with
a set of questions that I call my final
five and these are hopefully not in to
impossible to answer and I hope that
they'll leave the listeners with sort of
a taste of of you and the book as well
but but the what I would I like to kind
of just finish up with is how you come
to the conclusion with a you know very
interesting for especially for
physicists this famous famous book
Misner thorn and wheeler the book about
gravitation in fact called gravitation
and I don't spend too much time talking
about that book although it's clearly
had an impact on you both causing you to
have sciatica carrying it around so many
times and owning multiple copies of it
as I guess you do with with other books
as you mentioned in there as well a cold
and Turner and according to Amazon you
have not purchased a copy of losing the
number prized it's very very troubling
to me but I got a free copy oh you got a
free song I see I say yes indeed and I'm
just teasing I want to talk to you as a
fellow bookworm someone who loves books
thinking about that book and you go
through this incredible detail at
fascinating story about this massive you
know three phone books worth six point
seven eight pound look that's really the
foundation of many buildings literally
but also of Education for a theoretical
and experimental physicists like myself
yourself talking about legacies and
thinking about books like this one of
the things I most like to ask my guess
is where they see their legacy and how
their book if they are indeed our author
such as yourself in many of the I guess
or Arbonne at all
what what do you see is the legacy I've
asked this of many different people but
you know it in in the context of sort of
the DNA of the of the mind of the of the
universe of ideas you've you've added
this new strain helpful virus positive
virus now many of them and do you see
books as a legacy and
I wonder if you agree with this
statement that I heard and I like to ask
my author guests about would you rather
have one reader of quantum legacies or
the hippies a hundred years from now or
a thousand readers you know tomorrow
basically and I guess both is not on the
table no I was gonna say a thousand
years from now but let's see well yeah
let's be realistic then they're both be
Holograms and we'll be teaching in real
life so exactly right
well yeah so I do I think very much like
you Brian I I do love books that maybe
nothing not controversial stupid but I
mean I love I love I love physical books
I really still do I've gotten more
comfortable reading on my you know
tablet device but for different kinds of
way I think about books a lot
historically I've written about the
writing and reception of certain books
and I personally have found so
meaningful in my own you know
development and thinking and you know
it's it's it's sort of and Aish as I
work closely with the MIT press I share
their toriel board I think about how we
make books and get them into the world
from slightly more practical points of
view as well and it's given how much
time they take to to to write to review
to copy it it to to produce into into
stock shelves with it's it's remarkable
how short the attention can be that most
of them receive maybe we might say most
of deserves something the most received
meaning it is the rare book that
substantial numbers people will be
finding ourselves going back to multiple
decades after original publication and
so what sort of been fun for me in the
last several years as a historian is to
think about when some sort of round
number anniversary comes out 50 years
since blah 40 years since blah is to go
back and think about what are the
authors think they were doing back then
as well as we can reconstruct it from
the letters in cart you know
correspondence in drafts that survived
what a readers make of it at the time so
look up the book of views and some books
that have become you know undisputed
classics were panned at the time that
gives me a little where's the individual
received uh a lower than a four-star
review is first no no no that's not yet
to receive one but by the inverse
happens to people will celebrate these
books when they come out and you know it
becomes for who
what reasons a kind of flash in the pan
yeah so the books that break through the
books that we are still curious about
that will pull off our shelves and
reread generations later those actually
are pretty rare now the book format
enables that I mean I like to tell some
of my real digital fans that's a people
who I know who are super fond of
everything hyper hyper modern we can
still read Isaac Newton's notebooks or
Rene Descartes correspondence because
they used pen on paper and paper has a
much longer shelf life than my operating
system on my tablet right and so thank
goodness you know Galileo wasn't wasn't
using some version of some word
processors going to be unreadable ten
years later so there is a a literal
physical staying power to the printed
book that I am since very my percent by
historians profession couldn't really
exist without and I and I do think of
that we think about this thing as object
that we you know to get out of the
library can't a we can pass it down to
our friends or children or colleagues
and we can literally return to and the
object can be transporting and bring us
back I recently just reread Alan
Lightman is just absolutely just
charmingly beautiful novel Einsteins
dreams it came out my senior year of
college so that I already gets me
thinking about you know my younger self
and where was I when I was again
literally flipping through the pages on
my college campus what does it mean to
bring it off the shelf now in a very
different moment of my own life and
different safer world we have we can
have these kind of connections with with
the printed book and I don't mean to say
that we shouldn't have our ebooks but
there's something about that and I and
and like I said I loved the the task of
tracing through how did these objects
these special ones get put together how
are they thought of at the time what did
the authors hope what are the reviewers
think and then what do we make of them
from where we sit now and in in my own
most recent book you and I do that
exercise with a number of books that
have been kind of meaningful to me and
to many other colleagues and the one you
mentioned MTW is one of my favorites
bismuth or Nina we are wheeler because
it was sort of iconic it was super
strange when it first came out it was
intentionally kind of in a different
genre or form
and people are used to it has inspired
these ecstatic responses it was reviewed
as if it were a novel it's a 1,300 page
graduate level technical textbook with
so many different equations they had to
have multiple fonts and not just the
usual thought that you and I would use
today it's a monster of a book and it
was being reviewed food in like local
San Antonio newspapers as if everyone
should buy this thing it's the most
interesting thing you it's a talk of a
season how on earth could that have been
the case right I love thinking about
these books again as kind of objects in
the world because readers bring things
to them and that might not be the what
the authors thought it might not be what
we bring to them today and that's part
of what I love about this constant dance
of coming back to these books which can
open up new meanings to us now that
meant things differently back there and
I think they're just I'm just I love
that exercise I find it really
fascinating
yeah and it's such a tremendous
accomplishment to to leave not only you
know for your own kind of preservation
in the amber of history the sight the
smell the texture of a physical book of
course it's magical
I did I did Revere learn an interesting
fact that there are actually newer books
like Maxwell's electromagnet ISM and
Charles Darwin's Origin of Species which
even though they're written much later
than Galileo's books are actually much
more rare because the paper they were
printed on had a lot of acid in it and
it dissolves over time and becomes
incredibly unstable whereas the vellum
and the the parchment that essentially
that Galileo's books were published on
makes them much more durable and saying
thankfully for for Newton but yeah those
could get your copy of Darwin while you
can
speaking of evolution and and the DNA
that we that we both mutually see and
perceive through books speaking of books
the last kind of book question that I'll
ask is uh revolves around who would you
rather have read this book
someone who's skeptical of the
importance and the necessity for a yet
another quantum interpretation of
quantum mechanics or of characterization
of quantum mechanics in the 20th and
21st century we really need another book
or someone who loves your stuff and
loves to read everything you put
and fact check all your footnotes right
right right
well again hopefully some some
combination of all the above I did one
of things that I really enjoy it's
become a challenge I've sort of set for
myself because it's hard I'm certainly
hard for me I should say is trying to
describe these really pretty crazy
sounding ideas that people like you and
I have this great privilege to sit with
and play with all day in our
professional lives and try to convey
some part of that to non - non physicist
a non specialists at least to convey why
seemingly smart people would even take
that seriously why would keep us up at
night why we'd fight with each other in
college other names throughout history
and so in that sense the book is really
written in part for a kind of home team
of our colleagues in physics and
astrophysics in cosmology I hope they'll
find things they didn't know and would
find interesting but at least as much if
not more it really is written for people
who are curious about the modern science
is not necessarily immersed in them
themselves and who I hope can come to
appreciate a bit more of the embedding
of this quest to know unavoidably in in
these uncertainties of our social and
political worlds we're all people
Einstein was just a person - as was
Stephen Hawking we're all people in
times and places and some of the impacts
of that embeddedness can have without
our even recognizing it on the way we
ask questions and the way we interact
with colleagues and what we think is the
right question even to pursue that's
part of what I wanted to try to to
really grapple with in this book it is
as you mentioned early on it's that kind
of choose your an adventure it's because
it's a collection of essays they needn't
be read in order one needn't start on
page one and B and it's kind of
kaleidoscopic I wanted to be able to get
it shared themes from a few different
angles or like a like a prism you know
so a couple things will recur but you
don't have to kind of beat your head
against it for 30 pages it's like here's
one way of getting at that let's see it
from in a different setting because
because the ideas themselves are moving
targets and the people pursuing them are
embedded in a really these fast changing
currents so I wanted to convey some of
that the not just the humanists but the
embeddedness the real unavoidable
historical 'no Stute wry to find truths
that we hope will not be bound to time
in place we
you're bound in in history and hopefully
some of these ideas will indeed you know
kind of you take on a life of their own
no that's that's fascinating I couldn't
couldn't agree with you more
turning now back towards this the craft
of what you do and it's hard with people
like you because you do so many things
so well but the but there's a there's a
quote that appeals to me that I asked my
guests about I used it in in my book
losing the Nobel Prize sort of the
ending chapter as caught by Sauron
Kierkegaard who said that life can only
be understood backwards but must be
lived forwards and thinking of the
arthur c clarke quote that inspires the
name of this podcast which is Clarke's
second law you know his first laws that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
well his as the first guest on the into
the impossible podcast you'll remember
that on maybe you want I didn't but
anyway that the second law of arthur c
clarke is that the only way to find out
what is possible is to go a little bit
into the impossible so with
Kierkegaard's quote in mind that sort of
life only makes sense in Reverse but we
kind of have to live it with trepidation
going forward what what you know kind of
lessons have you learned or our concepts
or things that you might have felt were
impossible as a twenty year old a thirty
year old as many of our listeners are
that now seems seems achievable or has
been achieved because you took that
courageous venture into the impossible
well that's a great question i i i do i
i'm especially working on that cosmic
bell project that we talked about in
some detail at many points along that
that was about a five year adventure
we're not done we have new ideas we'd
like to work on but that the kind of
capstone really brought it together and
of course at four or five years a pretty
long time and throughout much of that
adventure and journey and heartbreak and
roller coaster and all this i literally
kept pinching myself sometimes i mean
little pictures because i couldn't
believe i had this opportunity on the
one hand to work with these unbelievably
gifted tireless just remarkably
hard-working smart very nice and
collegial
grad students and postdocs and at the
same time working with people that I had
literally read about when I was a high
school student when I was in in high
school in the 80s I was as I mentioned
enamored of these new popular books on
physics I read about Alan Guth and the
inflationary universe in a book by John
Gribbon but I loved going in search of
the Big Bang they came out in the mid
80s I learned about Anton Zeilinger in
some of the early efforts to test
quantum entanglement and similar books
from that period and here I was kind of
unbelievably able to work directly with
them and with this this larger team to
ask some kinds of questions that I'd
first heard about as a 16 or 17 year old
uh and that's I mean I just still feel
unbelievably lucky to have been able to
have that kind of a journey and to
participate so in the one hand I I see
this unbelievable energy and I it's not
maybe a little corny they're just
inspiration from these incredibly you
know kind of all in grad students and
postdocs who are doing things I I will
never be able to do I certainly can't do
now and it and they make it look easy
and the other hand connecting with these
people who helped get me even interested
in this stuff and who are still working
working day in and day out you know
after these very prestigious long
productive careers that's what I mean
about these Jim I talked about about
eleven book about these generations we
have that kind of connection as
educators as researchers we are this
unbelievable opportunity to work with
you know at least three if not more
generations and and that that itself
helps us know move helps us collectively
move through time even if alas we have
to go in one direction and not always
when we might prefer we're doing it in
this kind of collective way so and just
thinking about connecting as I say my
own kind of curiosities hope streams
clear misunderstandings and this steps
and then and then trying to kind of
bumble along and bumble through the
we're not doing it alone and and we and
we have many types of experiences and
wisdoms on which to build and that's
that's just a remarkable feature of our
line of work it's great great that's a
very beautiful way to put it so the last
question I have that I share with my
guest is whether or not what you do can
be taught we spoke a lot about pedagogy
some guests say it can't be he some say
they're special sauces is somehow you
know a byproduct of luck or circumstance
and others say you know they have a
unique ability for hard work but perhaps
other people could as well for someone
that is interested in pursuing the
many-fold careers that you've had author
teacher leader etc what what kind of
perspective do you bring do you feel
like it is a teachable skill is that
this is something that is possible to be
transmitted mentor to Protege I do think
so I think any of these we take the
writing one in particular and this book
really grew out it's a collection of
essays most of which almost all of which
I had originally published as kind of
one-off essays and I didn't think of
them as part of a larger project until
then in some cases some years later so
let's let's think about that example I
was certainly not trained as a writer in
any sense or an essayist I knew writers
whom I admired and who I'd read for
pleasure and and and but I was enough
I couldn't kind of reverse engineer it
just from reading great authors I mean I
certainly couldn't and so what I found
and I tried to really emphasize that in
the acknowledgments of the book where I
felt like it could be a bit more
expansive and that I I I had the great
opportunity to practice and to get a lot
of very patient feedback from some
professional from a number of
professional editors and they really
could teach me things I could be taught
to write down thankfully I'm still have
more plenty to learn but but I didn't
have to do it on my own and it wasn't
just that I you know read a book about
how to do it it was at that interactive
kind of dialogic back-and-forth
back-and-forth with as I say both
generous and often very patient editors
and so these things like you know think
about the structure of your essay don't
just sit down and write oh that's
helpful think about a kind of opening
hook think about where you want it to go
what's the don't bury the lead you know
don't wait to tell us the point of the
essay the very end
these are definitely teachable and there
were things that I frankly had to be
taught so that's evidence that they're
teachable and so so that's an example
from let's say they're the kind of right
the craft of writing let's say but I
absolutely have benefitted from very
specific kind of teachable moments from
from a dozen or more editors and a whole
range of kind of venues so yeah so I
think I think many things can be taught
of course it will take the hard work and
curiosity and the effort I don't mean to
say it's there's a formula to it but I
don't think it's I don't think it's
magic actually at least what what I do I
think some people did things that that
still look to me like magic and that's a
different maybe that can't be taught but
but the things that I know best they
absolutely can be taught and I and I'm
proof because I've had you know amazing
mentors and teachers along the way
phenomenon well David we've come to the
end of this very generous with your time
conversation I always think of you as a
as a quantum mensch and I always wish
there wasn't a continent between us
quite frankly and that we could spend
more time together
because I always delight to talk to you
you're you're such a amazing intellect
good friend a wonderful mentor teacher
and of course the you know associate
dean as I got to know you and loved you
as an associate dean I know your fellow
faculty are lucky to have you
the last part is called the plug zone
here you do not have a very active
social media presence I didn't see I
could find unless it might be in super
position somewhere so I will lik give
links to your website and to the book of
course will show the cover of the book
but just an opportunity are you working
on another book or you working on any
other projects you'd like our audience
to be on the lookout for as they come
down the pipeline later on sure yeah no
thank you Brian so I have a couple other
book projects we like to say book
projects because that way you're not on
the hook for when it's going to become
an actual book a couple one of which all
of which I'm very excited about one of
which Springs from the discussions we
were having I'm working exceptionally
slowly on an undergraduate textbook
early universe cosmology with my very
dear mentor and colleague Alan Guth and
so being immersed in histories of
textbooks that have meant so much to me
and other colleagues now you know
working hard to write a textbook is
actually awfully fun to kind of close
that loop a bit more that won't be out
anytime soon we're working on it I think
it hopefully will be a value once and
once we're done but that's one that's
it's again it's a sheer joy to to get to
work on so stay tuned in the you know in
the coming years
I'm working on a history book on aspects
of the history of Einstein's general
theory of relativity again close to both
of our hearts that also is a project
that I just thoroughly loved I've just
enjoyed I've been picking away at it and
able to write chapter versions here and
there but still partly because you know
cuz because there are a lot of things
going on it'll be a while to it's out
but it is one that I I look forward to
kind of reimbursing myself in now that
this books done and and other projects I
get to wrap up so those are to remember
that's wonderful congratulations on the
tremendous accomplishment of this book
quantum legacies I'll hold up a virtual
copy here on my iPad device until I can
get my copy delivered from the bookstore
we are giving away books copies of the
book once things open up for reviewers
of the internet into the impossible
podcast on the iTunes Store so please
subscribe rate and review um-- - may win
a copy of your own book david that
wouldn't that be a treat but it will
certainly be a treat to get you back on
whenever you have anything new and
hopefully we'll get together under warm
circumstances and we can we can share
some some more memories in the future
thank you so much David it's always a
treat and the special one today
congratulations alright thanks so much I
really appreciate it and stay well and
stay well do to your family and those
are the people who watch the podcast as
well thanks thank you dammit
[Music]
while any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic